eppingen in bad neuenahr-ahrweiler mitte
august knapp fünf wochen nach der
flutkatastrophe sind dieselben die die
wassermassen hier angerichtet haben noch
überall sichtbar 40 häuser stehen in
diesem neubaugebiet jetzt sind fast alle
unbewohnbar
so auch das haus von heimen und nadine
templeton im august treffen wir das paar
mit ihrem sohn terence zum ersten mal
damals zeigen sie uns was von ihrem haus
noch übrig ist
[Musik]
raus muss wer seid ihr durch geklettert
auf die ganze nacht saß die kleinfamilie
auf dem dach ihres neubaus und bangte um
ihr leben die 400 meter von ihrem haus
entfernt war zu einem reißenden strom
geworden erst am nächsten morgen wurden
sie mit einem boot von der feuerwehr
gerettet
viel gearbeitet das anders aufgebaut
danach war es weg der schaden allein für
das gebäude liegt bei rund 300.000 euro
immerhin hatten sie eine versicherung
abgeschlossen die die kosten für den
wiederaufbau übernehmen wird aber nur an
dieser stelle die familie wirkt damals
noch unentschlossen ob sie wirklich hier
bleiben möchte im prinzip müssen wir ja
wir finanzieren das haus wir müssen hier
aufbauen wir könnten natürlich dann
sagen wir verkaufen ist wer kauft hier
in der gegend ein haus ist die nächste
frage und dann findet erst mal was
anderes
familie moi treffen wir im august nur
eine straße weiter zusammen mit einem
gutachter die moors haben keine
versicherung und sind damit auf die
staatlichen flut hilfen angewiesen dafür
brauchen sie ein professionelles
gutachten über den schaden von wissen ob
es nicht tatsächlich das lohnt hier
nochmal eine sanierung durchzuführen
das hochwasser stand bis zum
obergeschoss rund 300.000 euro hatte
allein das haus gekostet gutachter ralf
steinsfeld heute sein urteil lässt sich
das einstige zuhause der muss noch
retten sind schon elementare schäden da
aber es ist nicht unrettbar keine ganz
schlechte nachricht für die moors eine
sanierung wäre immerhin möglich aber die
angst vor einer erneuten flut sie bleibt
die angst ist berechtigt bereits ende
august treffen wir an der universität
siegen paolo reggiani erforscht zu
wasser wirtschaftlichen risiken und
klimafolgen er warnt schon 2016 habe es
an der aa eine kritische hochwasserlage
gegeben aus der aufarbeitung der
statistik ist oder der der messreihen
die wir haben ist es eigentlich gar
nicht mal so unwahrscheinlich dass das
wieder auftritt wie sehen sie das denn
ist ein wiederaufbau
wirklich sinnvoll oder überhaupt sicher
ja ich persönlich würde es nicht tun
doch entgegen der warnungen von experten
und klimaforschern dürfen jetzt die
meisten häuser im aartal wieder
aufgebaut werden und das obwohl die
neuen überschwemmungs karten die das
land rheinland pfalz im oktober
veröffentlicht jetzt weite teile des
aals als überschwemmungsgebiete
ausweisen auch die gemarkung heimerzheim
normalerweise ist das bauen hier
gesetzlich verboten für die meisten
betroffenen gebäude im aartal gilt
jedoch bestandsschutz so auch für das
haus der moz obwohl es nun offiziell im
überschwemmungsgebiet liegt könnten sie
ihr haus ohne auflagen sanieren
ende november treffen wir familie [ __ ]
ein weiteres mal es wird klar in einem
überschwemmungsgebiet kommt eine
sanierung für sie eigentlich nicht mehr
in frage sie hatten sich auf die
versprechen von bundes und
landesregierung verlassen dass den
flutopfern schnell geholfen wird doch so
einfach ist es nicht wir können sich
nicht hinstellen können sagen wir machen
alles für die bürger wissen aber im
klartext das eigentlich gar nicht dazu
in der lage sind einfach wegziehen um an
einem hochwassersicheren ort neu
aufzubauen können die moors nicht denn
eine finanzielle unterstützung für einen
neubau an einem anderen ort bekommen sie
nur wenn sie schon ein weiteres
grundstück besitzen das haben sie aber
nicht dann steckt man ganz viel geld in
die sanierung ein deutlich mehr als ein
abriss neubau auch letzten endes kosten
würde das ist schon alleine würde ich
sagen naja aus sicht des steuerzahlers
würde ich sagen
grenzwertig in ihrer not wenden sie sich
an die zuständige behörde die
wasserwirtschaftsverwaltung in rheinland
pfalz sie ist für den schutz der
menschen vor den gewässern im land
verantwortlich und soll die kommunen bei
der suche nach geeigneten einsatz
wohnbauflächen unterstützen doch seit
mehreren wochen warten die moors auf
antwort die stadthalle in cochem zell
auf einer infoveranstaltung für
hochwassergeschädigte spricht der
abteilungsleiter wasserwirtschaft
joachim gehrke als wir ihn fragen wie es
bei den muss weitergehen soll kann er zu
dem konkreten fall nichts sagen da für
allgemeine hinweise wir können natürlich
hilfestellungen geben bei der frage wie
kann man im hochwasser bereich im
überschwemmungsgebiet hochwasser
angepasst bauen zu fragen der förderung
versicherung und so weiter können wir
als wasserwirtschaftsverwaltung
keine aussagen treffen den betroffenen
helfen soll die isb die investitions und
strukturbank denn sie verwaltet das geld
aus dem hilfspaket der bundesregierung
für den wiederaufbau bei ihr müssen
betroffene anträge auf finanzielle
unterstützung einreichen doch werk ein
ersatzgrundstück hat ist aufgeschmissen
die behörde teilt mit zitat
der antrag im esb kundenportal sieht als
pflichtfelder vor das bereits angaben
zum ersatz vorhaben inklusive flurstück
angaben gemacht werden
familie [ __ ] hat kein flurstück und die
behörden helfen nicht scheinbar haben
sie nur eine option wir werden jetzt
hier so wie es aussieht gezwungen werden
zu sanieren auf teufel komm raus und
dann müssen wir tatsächlich danach noch
entscheiden ob wir selber tatsächlich
das haus dann bewohnen können und wollen
das ist der nächste schritt also ich
finde das alles sehr sehr unglücklich
dass mit den großzügigen hilfen von bund
und land hatten sich die moors anders
vorgestellt sie werden nun viel geld in
die sanierung ihres hauses investieren
mitten in einem überschwemmungsgebiet
wohl wissend dass die nächste flut
kommen kann das haus der templeton die
familie hat sich inzwischen entschieden
sie wollen bleiben und haben bereits mit
der sanierung begonnen die versicherung
bezahlt bisher alle baukosten doch
allein auf die schutzmaßnahmen des
landes will familienvaters heimen
templeton sich nicht verlassen wir
machen auf jeden fall treppe nach oben
für den fall der fälle dass wir halt
schnell auf sach kommen und wir können
natürlich jetzt
hochwasserschutzwände an die fenster
bauen
könnte da ein bisschen absichern da
hoffen dass
ja was vom land und von der regierung
kommt das
rückhaltebecken entstehen
vielleicht eine dämme
trotz der schwierigen monate freut sich
templeton mit seiner familie nun auf
weihnachten in seinem haus sammelt er
spenden aus ganz deutschland
weihnachtsdeko die sich seine nachbarn
beim abholen können weil
es eine kleinigkeit ist das ist einfach
schön das einfach weil jeder hat seinen
komplett verloren ist aber wenn du es
auch im speicher gehabt hast du glück
gehabt viele hatten es unten im keller
oder in kleinen räumen und haben nichts
mehr und jetzt hast du dir so ein
bisschen was
[Musik]
nächstes jahr soll das weihnachtsfest
wieder in seinem haus stattfinden und er
hofft dass dann seine familie die
katastrophe überstanden hat